de facebook a meter el gigante de las
redes sociales decidió cambiar su nombre
es hora de que adoptemos una nueva marca
de empresa para abarcar todo lo que
hacemos para reflejar quiénes somos y lo
que esperamos construir me enorgullece
anunciar que a partir de hoy nuestra
empresa ahora es meta
la meta para metaversos realidades
virtuales compartidas con posibilidades
infinitas donde los avatar son los
protagonistas según zuckerberg será el
nuevo internet móvil el cambio de nombre
ocurre cuando la empresa enfrenta un
escrutinio público a comienzos de
octubre francés joven antiguo
trabajadora de facebook sacó a la luz
comprometedores secretos las directivas
de la red social habrían ignorado o
minimizado las advertencias internas
acerca de las consecuencias negativas y
muchas veces dañinas que sus algoritmos
han causado en todo el mundo la versión
de facebook que existe hoy está
destrozando nuestras sociedades y
provocando violencia épica en todo el
mundo para algunos analistas el cambio
de nombre no es más que una cortina de
humo
simplemente dejar las cosas sucias a un
lado o barrer las debajo de la alfombra
tienes que abordar esas cosas de frente
y eso es algo que no vimos en esta
charla de zuckerberg y compañía camping
a pesar de que mark zuckerberg anunció
que en la unión europea' crearía 10.000
puestos de trabajo esto no parece
suficiente para acallar las
investigaciones éticas en contra de su
empresa para salvar a facebook
zuckerberg que necesitará más que un
cambio de nombre